an actor's tribute to two towering Kings
of cool a running joke through the
franchise and oh so many references the
John Wick franchise yeah or thinking
it's back the John Wick Series has
always had a penchant for paying tribute
to other movies and chapter 4 continues
this trend first up is Lawrence of
Arabia and the 1962 epics memorable shot
hailed by some as the greatest single
cut of all time jumping from Peter
O'Toole blowing out a match to the
Desert Horizon at Sunrise chapter 4
replicates the transition by having the
Bowery King blow out a match before
cutting to the Desert Horizon where Jon
is engaged in a horse Chase later on
there is a reference to Quentin
Tarantino's Kill Bill with Kane telling
Akira he will be waiting for her to take
revenge after he kills her father it's
the same message the bride delivers to
vernita Green's daughter after killing
her mother
still feel
about it
I'll be waiting what's more Kane's
character a blind assassin who fights
primarily with a sword is in the
tradition of the Japanese zatoichi the
blind swordsman series which ran for 25
films with its Mainline entries alone
not to mention other films and
television that has incorporated the
character there is also subtle homage to
Walter Hill's wild 1979 classic the
Warriors both movies have a radio DJ
tracking the heroes as they work their
way through a city of enemies both films
shoot the DJ in extreme close-ups
rendering them both intimate and
Anonymous with only a mouth and
microphone visible Tarantino similarly
cribbed the shot in Pulp Fiction when
Mia Wallace talked to Vincent Vega
through her house intercom John Wick
takes plenty of damage but he also seems
nearly indestructible throughout the
series while he can come out on top in
almost every scenario he has always had
one significant weakness cars more
specifically cars crashing into him from
his right side on the commentary track
for John Wick chapter 2 director Chad
stachelski and star Keanu Reeves joke
about how John only weakness is getting
hit by cars on his right side he somehow
never sees or hears them coming from
this blind spot despite otherwise having
seemingly Supernatural spatial awareness
getting struck by a car from the left is
how Jon winds up captured and bound to a
chair back in the first movie after it
happened a few other times stalski
noticed this trend he has since turned
it into a running joke throughout the
series this continues in chapter 4 as
Jon is struck by multiple cars on his
right side in the span of just a few
minutes all in the Paris portion of the
film if you're in the know it's a funny
callback for Jon he really needs to get
better at looking both ways
these so-called Elder is one of the more
mysterious figures in the entire John
Wick Universe first introduced in John
Wick chapter 3 Parabellum John made an
arduous Trek through the desert just to
reach him at different points the Elder
has been described as being the head of
the high table even perhaps above the
high table altogether
I seek a meeting with the one who sits
above the table he calls the shots makes
the rules for the entire assassin
underworld and holds a position of
extreme importance which makes it extra
noteworthy that he was replaced between
movies in Chapter 3 The Elder was played
by Syed tagmohi veteran of films like La
Ain and Wonder Woman for chapter 4 the
role was recast with George giordu with
this recasting the Elder's presence has
gone from minor supporting character in
chapter 3 to an even smaller presence in
chapter four The Character only has a
couple of lines before Jon kills him the
appearance is so brief in fact that many
may not even realize the recasting
chapter 4 does actually include a quick
line of dialogue about how the current
Elder replaced the former one but there
is no clear reason for why this Changing
of the Guard occurred
skilled martial artist and action movie
veteran Scott Adkins plays the role of
Killa in John Wick chapter 4 but unless
you are a hardcore action movie fan and
regularly view Adkins frequent direct to
video movies you might not recognize him
Killa is Jon's assassination Target in
Berlin an obese car dealing nightclub
gangster with asthma Jon needs to kill
him in order to secure the support of
the ruska Roma and use their crust to
challenge the Marquee to a duel for the
role the fit Adkins was hidden behind
extensive Prosthetics and even adopts a
German accent another eye-catching
design element of Killa is his gold
teeth perhaps a reference to the
gold-toothed character Atkins played in
2019's avengement getting even more
granular this is the second time that
Adkins has been at odds with Donnie Yen
in a fourth installment of an iconic
action series he first fought Yen's main
character in Ip Man 4 the finale in 2019
playing the main villain a racist
American army Sergeant
perhaps the most iconic scene from the
original John Wick film came via an
extended action sequence in the red
circle nightclub chapter 4 brings the
beat back the first part of that
sequence took place in the bath house
below the club scored by the Kalida song
think once the shootout progressed
upstairs to the dance floor the
soundtrack kicked into high gear as the
lay Castlevania song Led spirals took
over the song was named after the
swirling black and white imagery
displayed on the nightclub's LED screen
and composed for the film three movies
later the same needle drop gets a
reprise in John Wick chapter 4 in a
soundtrack filled with memorable songs
LED spirals once again stands out
pulling off the impressive feat of being
the only track to become a musical
highlight of multiple John Wick films
the big show-stopping action sequence at
the end of John Wick chapter 4 involves
the titular character's deadly Ascent up
a massive staircase John needs to meet
the Marquee at La basilique du Sacre
kurdemon Mart at sunrise for a duel but
to get there he first needs to fight his
way past dozens of armed Thugs and climb
the 222 steps to the top of the hill
that staircase is real and it really
does consist of 222 steps and leads
directly to the Sacre curb Basilica just
as it does in the movie the staircase is
big enough to be considered its own
Street in the Iman Mart District of
Paris and is known as Rue foyotere the
location is a popular tourist attraction
a frequent subject of acclaimed
photographers and has been featured in
other movies including the 1984 French
film Le ripu parts of the steps and the
socrate her Basilica were also home to
an important sequence in Amelie and a
matching staircase on the opposite side
of the hill was used for the opening
scene of the John frankenheimer flick
Ronin in real life there are cable cars
that go up and down the hill right
before inside the staircase these were
of course hidden from view in the film
as John's Ascent would have been made
significantly easier if he could have
just hailed a cable car John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum was the first movie
in the series to introduce the heavily
armored soldiers who work for the high
table these enemies were not just highly
skilled and equipped with high-powered
Weaponry but they were also practically
bulletproof requiring Jon to get
creative to take them out we may have to
consider our choices carefully
boy the match has changed during your
time away these heavily armored high
table soldiers make a welcome return in
chapter four this time however they show
up in Osaka Japan and their bulletproof
armor has now been altered slightly to
better suit the Japanese setting they
now more closely resemble the armor worn
by Samurai Warriors back in the days of
feudal Japan particularly in the new
design of their face masks while the NYC
high table soldiers wore blank ballistic
helmets The Masks of their Osaka
counterparts more closely resemble menpo
traditional intricate half masks worn by
Samurai
if John Wick chapter 4 feels distinctly
different from the previous films in a
big way it might be because it was
written by different people from the
director to the producers to the Stars
the same creative team has remained
largely consistent throughout the series
the one major creative fluctuation
however has been Derek colstad Kolstad
was the original screenwriter of the
first movie back when it was just a spec
script titled scorn he was the Lone
screenwriter on John Wick chapter 2 as
well when chapter 3 Parabellum rolled
around Kolstad remained involved but
other writers began getting their hands
dirty as well he retained Seoul Story by
credit but was now just one of four
screenwriters contributing to the
screenplay but chapter 4 Kolstad was out
of the picture entirely colsted has been
open about the fact that it wasn't his
decision to leave the series saying the
studio simply didn't invite him back
coolstad has kept busy in the meantime
however with the John Wick flavored
action movie Nobody as a member of the
writing team on the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and as co-creator of the
quibby Roku series die heart the extent
of his involvement in the upcoming
Continental spin-off TV series remains
to be seen
long before he made the transition to
English language films Donnie Yen was a
legend within the Hong Kong action film
industry he has always called Bruce Lee
his Idol and he saw an opportunity to
take influence from and pay tribute to
Lee in John Wick chapter 4. as mentioned
in the official Lionsgate production
notes for chapter 4 Yen chose Kane's
wardrobe himself he based the look on an
outfit worn by Lee out of character in
an old interview a black and white suit
and shirt with a skinny black tie since
he had already played a blind fighter in
Rogue one yen was on the lookout for
ways to separate the two characters and
help them stand apart plenty of
distinguishing detail was in the script
and choreography already but Yen chose
to play up Kane's personality as a cross
between Bruce Lee and American actor
Steve McQueen who had a reputation as
the king of cool you believe what you
want
you work your side of the street and
I'll work on it the Lee influence can be
seen in the wardrobe along with some of
Kane's mannerisms the McQueen influence
can also be seen in Kane's relaxed
nonchalant attitude even as bullets are
flying and swords are swinging as Kane
takes his time to calmly eat and drink
in the middle of an action sequence it's
hard not to be reminded of those two
legendary tough guys
the massive set piece at ruefoyo tear
serves as the action climax of John Wick
chapter 4. before the story comes to a
close with the slower paced Duel at La
basilique do Sacre occur between John
and Kane after John painstakingly fights
to the top of the 222-step staircase
he's greeted with a kick that sends him
tumbling all the way back down the fall
is so long and drawn out that it becomes
hilarious even as you feel bad for Jon's
pain and struggle Die Hard fans of the
John Wick series will recall that this
is actually the second time the series
has used a prolonged fall down a huge
staircase for a joke in the middle of a
big action sequence the previous
iteration was back in Chapter 2 during
the portion of the film set in Italy as
Jon and Cassian fight they repeatedly
tumble down several flights of steps and
comically exaggerated fashion finally
winding up in a courtyard below where
they continue to Duke it out for a
series as kinetic as John Wick it feels
fitting for its version of a callback to
be based on a physical stunt
[Music]
foreign